scientists build on the shoulders of
giants
in fact those shoulders most often are
data
[Music]
biology has completely changed in the
last 20 years
and the big change has been that we can
generate massive amounts of data
alpha fault is an ai system developed by
deep mind and what it can do is take a
protein amino acid sequence and it can
create these very accurate 3d models of
that protein
when alpha fold
does its predictions it can generate
millions of protein structures it's like
having a different microscope on the
world of molecules of life
when we launched off of db last july it
was 365 000 protein predictions and then
it grew to about 1 million and now it's
two orders of magnitude more
embol ebi is the home in europe of most
biomolecular data and so it was a very
natural joining up with deepmind to take
their predicted models and make them
available for everybody
so one of the challenges with the data
that we have from from this
collaboration is the size of the data
sets and because of that we had to get
creative in in the infrastructure and
especially how it will scale and
databases are a little bit like plants
they need
pruning they need regenerating they need
fertilizing in some way
we are taking advantage of the google
cloud infrastructure we had to make sure
that we really have something that
scales well that can continue to grow
having all these millions of structures
will change the face of biology again
it's disrupting both the field of
structural biologists but it's also
empowering them to solve structures that
they couldn't before
i mean this comes down to medicine
agriculture biotech everything there are
many applications
it's like a shop you can go in and just
get your favorite protein and look at it
instantly i mean it's just fantastic
[Music]